WECHAT:
If you follow the tech world,
you’re probably familiar with the Chinese giant
Tencent. They are the largest Chinese tech company
with a market cap of $376 billion and they have
their arms in everything from gaming and social
media to payments and investing. But likely their
most notable product is their super app WeChat.
WeChat is basically ubiquitous with a total of 827
million users within just China. And this ubiquity
isn’t surprising given that WeChat attempts to
do everything. You can buy groceries, book planes
and hotels, make payments, message people, read
the news, get food delivery, have a video call,
play video games, and basically whatever else you
want. For years, American companies have looked at
WeChat with pure envy as they too want a super app
that encompasses every aspect of people’s lives.
And it seems that the latest tech billionaire to
jump on this band wagon is Elon Musk who wants to
turn X into an everything app. He says that for
X to succeed, the platform needs to compete with
YouTube, LinkedIn, Facetime, dating apps, and for
some reason, the entire banking industry. Given
that Elon has basically infinite resources,
actually developing such an app and putting
in front of people would not be too difficult,
but actually getting people to use it, well,
that’s a whole nother story. Google, Facebook,
and Apple have been trying to do this for over
a decade now, slowly expanding to one industry
after another. But to this day, they’re all very
much dependent on their hero product. 58% of all
of Google’s revenue for example still comes from
search ads. 52% of Apple’s revenue still comes
from the iPhone. And 96% of Meta’s revenue
still comes from just Facebook and Instagram.
And that’s despite these companies expanding
to dozens and dozens of sectors and industries
often betting as much as a $100 billion. Clearly,
infinite money and resources haven’t allowed any
of these guys to create a true super app. So,
here’s why a super app has never worked in
America and why X won't be any different.
PUBLIC HESITANCE:
Likely the biggest factor preventing a super app
from blowing up in America is public hesitance.
The majority of the public already feels that big
tech has too much power and they feel no need to
start using even more offerings from any one of
these companies. And whenever a big tech company
tries to push such a vision, people not only tend
to not buy in but often resist. Likely the best
example of this was with Google+. If you’re not
familiar with Google+, it was basically Google’s
attempt to take on Facebook and create their own
social media platform. They were relatively
early to social media as well given that the
network launched in mid 2011. On paper, Google+
actually started off pretty strong. Within 2 weeks
of launch, they got 10 million users. Within a
month, they had 25 million users. And within 2
years, they had over half a billion users. Surely,
this was a massive success right? Well, that is
until you peel back the layers. You see, while
Google was able to get a bunch of users on board,
these weren’t exactly excited or loyal users.
Rather, Google+ was forced onto these users. For
example, Google made it nearly impossible to
open a Gmail account without creating a Google+
profile. They also locked a bunch of useful
functionality behind a Google+. If you wanted to
see reviews from your friends, you needed Google+.
If you wanted to see the leaderboards on the Play
Store, you needed Google+. If you wanted to use
Google Hangouts, you needed Google+. Likely the
worst infraction though was when Google required
users to have a Google+ account to leave comments
on YouTube. This move generated so much backlash
that one of YouTube’s founders, Jawed Karim,
came out of his 8 year slumber to say “why the
f do i need a google+ account to comment on a
video?” All of this backlash would lead to
Gooogle rolling back many of these policies,
but it’s not like things would’ve played out
any differently even if they didn’t roll these
back. The reality was that while they were
able to get over half a billion accounts,
90% of user sessions lasted less than 5 seconds,
and Google would eventually end up shutting down
the platform in 2019. Now, you might be inclined
to say that this failure was largely just because
Google didn’t understand the social media space,
but honestly I don’t think that would’ve made
much of a difference which brings us into our
next example: Threads. I think we can all agree
that Meta is the undisputed king of social media
with multiple platforms with billions of users
each. So, you would think that they would
have a great shot at taking down Twitter,
especially given the poor optics after
Elon’s takeover. And to Threads credit,
they did have an insane launch reaching 100
million users within just 5 days. But, this was
followed by an explosive fall as well as Threads
would lose 80% of its daily active users within
just 1 month. And Google+ and Threads are just
2 notable examples. There’s plenty of examples
of this across tech such as the Microsoft Zune,
the Windows Phone, Bing, Edge, the Google Pixel,
Google Meets, Google Classroom, Bing Maps,
Google Bard, and on and on and on. It seems
that these tech leaders think that people will be
super ecstatic about having yet another big tech
account or service. They expect people to be like
“OH WOW! I can do Twitter on Threads now??? This
is a gamechanger. I can’t wait to ditch Twitter.”
In reality, people are more like “Oh cool,
Meta has a new app now? I’ll check it out.” None
of this is to say that these companies can’t
launch a successful product in an adjacent or even
completely different industry. But the bottomline
is that these company’s resources and ubiquity
doesn’t exactly make it any more likely that these
new products succeed especially on the scale that
you would expect from these companies because it’s
only these companies and their leaders who are
jumping up and down about the idea of a super app.
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE:
Sometimes, big tech is able to
overcome the odds and launch a new successful
widely used product in a completely different
industry. But they’re not home free yet because
now, they have to make the venture actually
worthwhile which is an even bigger challenge.
Likely the best example of this is Apple’s foray
into the financial industry. In early 2019, Apple
announced that they were gonna launch a credit
card. A credit card that easily integrated into
the Apple ecosystem, came with a beautiful UI,
and encouraged strong financial habits. From the
very beginning, credit card enthusiasts weren’t
a big fan of this card. While they didn’t have
anything particularly bad to say about the card,
they simply felt that there were better options
on the market in terms of rewards and benefits.
But despite their concerns, the Apple card would
go onto be a massive success amongst the general
public growing to over 6 million card holders. It
turns out that the average person far preferred
the simplicity and convenience of the Apple Card
over maximizing credit card points with Amex
or Chase. And that’s still the case to this day,
people still really like the Apple Card. The same,
however, cannot be said about Goldman Sachs,
the issuer of the Apple Card who has lost
over $1 billion largely due to Apple’s lack of
understanding of the credit card market. You see,
Apple largely approached the Apple Card with the
tech mindset and that’s largely why it was so well
received but this was also the card’s biggest
pitfall. For example, with tech, you want your
products to be as widely accessible as possible.
That’s why Apple kept the credit requirements
for the Apple Card super low. They wanted it to
be as easily accessible as possible and make it
easy for first time credit card holders to build
their credit. But, while that’s a great sentiment,
it also led to a quarter of their credit card
loans going out to people with credit scores
below 660 leading to the worst bank loss rate of
any big US card issuer. But not only is the Apple
Card losing money on its sub prime customers but
they’re also not making any money on their good
standing customers. Thanks to the Apple’s Cards
great UI and insistence that you pay off your
credit card bills, making money on good standing
customers is also nearly impossible. This isn’t
to say that Apple has to be predatory in order to
make money. Many Amex cards, for example, don’t
even allow customers to carry balances, but Amex
is still able to make a bunch of money from these
customers because they charge annual membership
fees and have other modes of monetization. Apple,
however, is stuck in a very tricky situation.
Their sub prime customers are defaulting left and
right, credit card enthusiasts don’t want anything
to do with the Apple Card, and their average
customers always pay off their entire balance and
never pay any interest. Yeah, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that Apple has agreed to end
their credit card and savings account partnerships
with Goldman Sachs. But honestly, I don’t think
Apple could’ve really avoided this fate. The
reality is that it takes time to truly understand
and compete in an industry such as credit cards.
Immediately launching to 6 million card holders
much of whom have never had a credit card before
is bound to cause issues which brings me into the
fundamental difference between China and America.
A FREE MARKET:
I don’t want to get too political here but the
reality is that launching a product in America and
China are very different. For a product to truly
be successful in China, you very much need the
blessing of the CCP which companies like Tencent
already have. And that’s why they’re able to
expand to any industry or sector with ease.
They’re often the biggest player in that industry
or they’re even the first player in that industry.
This makes capturing market share a walk in the
park but it’s completely different in America.
When an American company tries to create a super
app and expand to different industries, they’re
competing with highly established and competitive
players and brands. Apple for example was taking
on American Express, Chase, Citi, Capital one, and
all the other big banks. But, we don’t even have
to look into a different industry. This is true
within the tech industry itself. With Google+,
Google was competing against Meta. With Bing and
Edge, Microsoft was competing against Google.
With the Windows Phone, Microsoft was competing
against Apple and Google, and so on. Any industry
that these guys want to expand to is already
dominated by one of their biggest rivals and
unless these guys let up or drop the ball for some
reason, expanding here is nearly impossible. So,
ironically, one of the biggest factors preventing
a Tencent style monopoly is the big tech
oligopaly. None of them are going to let the other
eat their lunch. But even putting that aside,
Americans simply aren’t interested in super app.
In fact, they actually like having separation.
Take the financial industry for example. You can
have basically any one of your financial needs
be taken care of by Chase or Wells Fargo or any
one of the big banks. But the average American
doesn’t just have 1 Chase account, they actually
have 25-40 financial accounts. They have a few
checking accounts, a few savings accounts, 1 or 2
HSA accounts, a couple of credits cards, a couple
of payment platforms, a couple of investing and
trading platforms, a few loan providers, and a few
financial managment software providers. The reason
being that one they like separation, and two, each
account is good a something specfiic whether that
be investing or credit cards or mobile payments
or whatever. It’s the same thing with tech.
People have their favorite social media apps,
their messaging apps, their streaming services,
their games, their browsers, their emails, their
operating systems, and so on. Americans tend to
choose the one the like the most from each sector
to create an assortment of tech services that
let them enjoy the best of all words like a true
free market. And until that changes and Americans
want a product just because its from X or Meta or
Google or whatever, big tech really has no chance
of creating a true super app. With historically
high interest rates, the appeal bills and bonds is
the higher than ever, yet traditional brokerages
haven’t really adapted with the times. They
still expect people to use clunky bond tables,
scroll through long overwhleming lists, and even
use virtual keyboards till recently. And that’s
why we created our own modern bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust, so that you too can lock in high
yields. Also, choosing a strong user experience
doesn’t mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo
account is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all
funds deposited on the platform will be maintained
by our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers,
who has experience managing $373 billion
worth of assets over the past 45 years. So,
if you’re looking for a modern way to invest
in bonds, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below. Would you want a
super app? Comment that down below. Also,
it looks like surprisingly OG Facebook is
the closest to creating such a super app
atleast within the social media space.
Check out this video to learn more.